jodie foster's curtain hollywood spans
more than five decades but she's still a
baby she's a trailblazer in the industry
with hit movies like you remember panic
room and flight plan she won two Academy
Awards for her performances in the
accused I remember that Silence of the
Lambs remember that too she sits in the
director's chair for her latest project
it's the Emmy winning Netflix series
called Black Mirror it's a science
fiction anthology series described as a
modern take on the twilight zone she
directed the premiere episode it's
called Archangel where a mother turns to
new surveillance technology to keep her
daughter safe you had a recommendation
so Sarah will be part of our trial
period well it's been tested though
right and it's not like a guinea fast
it's off oh wait that's it perfectly
safe this is just as fine tuning our
subscription model before the full
launch we're getting feedback on which
features their customers use most in the
real world response so far is just
incredible the sense of security peace
of mind I mean the stories we've been
hearing there's really inspirational
okay then oh you got out just at the
part where they're gonna put welcome
Jodie Foster to studio 57 hello Jodie
hello there or should we say Jodie
bloody Foster because the producer said
that when they first heard you were even
interested they said there's no way we
get Jodie bloody Foster but you agreed
because what
well because it's an amazing show
amazing show and a beautiful episode
I've worked with for Netflix before and
you know it's it is kind of like working
for God when you work for nothing
it was black we're a series you had been
watching is that what it would drew you
to you know I didn't know anything about
it and I just Ben was having a
conversation with one of the executives
over there and boom owning the state of
the movie business and saying that I
really wanted to do feature-length films
on on streaming so yeah this is this is
the way to go well describe what what
you're talking about there that scene
that we just missed the technology there
is a device I can't tell ya I won't be
able to watch it so I can't know much
more about it there's a device that
allows you to keep your child safe and
of course every that's really not
telling much about
look I've always wondered I've always
thought about this man actually whether
you could implant something in them in
order to monitor them most parents that
I know to have used the find your iPhone
to know where their kids are all the
time who have their iPhone so the idea
of surveilling or keeping track of your
kids and what the consequences of that
like everything in black mirror you know
technology is really just a reflection
of our own messed up psychologies and
the technology itself is benign it
doesn't have feelings it just does what
we asked it to do and unfortunately it
highlights the crazy dynamics and
psychology of our our family lives and
of parenting where the tighter you
squeeze it's like a bar soap the tighter
you squeeze the faster it slips out of
your hand yeah I'm you know you've seen
that movie boyhood in some ways this
film has that similar feeling where you
see a child you start with a child from
the beginning from the time that she's
born and then you follow her until her
the end of her adolescence and there's
something you know you feel possessive
of her and you feel possessive of that
life there's a part of you that wants to
take care of her and there's a part of
you that wants to handicap her to stop
her growth and Jodi what do you say it's
a mother and a daughter that's not
spoiling anything we see that how do you
think that was different you know they
they say you raise daughters and you let
sons grow up is that a part of the
dynamic could it have worked with a
mother and son I we just would have been
a different movie with a mother and son
is yeah my first movie I directed was a
little man Tate about a mother and a son
and it's a very different relationship
and it's one that's fascinating to
explore but it's very different because
you have two boys right I have two boys
but I was raised by single mom and our
relationship was fraught and interesting
she was my manager she worked with me my
whole life and that when we had to pull
apart was very difficult that struggle
was very difficult and you know what
I'll say the the producer said about you
is that you didn't just do it you also
became very engaged in the process you
were phoning in notes you were saying I
think we ought to do this is that
normally how you handle directions under
you that you get you go all-in when
you're doing a project yeah director
they know what really getting when they
get you it's certainly in features
that's what you're doing features and
the fascinating thing about black mirror
is that unlike regular episodic
television where directors are brought
on very soon before the project and and
they're really just sort of
accomplishing the tone of the film the
tone of the series with black mirror it
is they they are small indie films so
ever the brand-new cast members brand
new crew members you you make a decision
about everything
how does it how's the creative
commitment different with acting versus
directing it's it's polar opposite
really it's a complete commitment to be
director and in some ways you know what
because I do both and one part of me
likes to play characters that aren't me
and so I ask questions you know what
would happen if I this happened to me
and how would I survive as a director
it's just the opposite I think you're
always you're always saying you know Who
am I and that's really what the that's
really what a director does Jodi what's
your take on the me to movement and the
latest revelations it started with
Harvey Weinstein I thought Jane
Rosenthal said it best right she said
Pandora's Box is open and Pandora is
pissed right so as we sit here today
what are your thoughts you know a lot
has happened since the story first night
broke I'm not a sound bite person I I'm
like hours person I like to talk about
things for hours I'm not very good in
140 characters I feel like it's such a
complicated issue and one that week it
is a watershed moment 40 but it's it's
an amazing moment of time and you know
in order to do it justice I think we
need a bigger dialogue and we need a
much more complicated dialogue but this
time is necessary and I'm really looking
forward to what happens next like all
social justice movements I think we're
all looking forward to how we can heal
and we want to hear other voices want to
hear the other side as well and we want
to hear in order to really change things
in justice by a Twitter is not the rest
not good you know it's so interesting
you say that because I use the word
reckoning on the air and I've been
thinking a lot about it some point will
reach a period of reconciliation and
that's the next part of this yeah I mean
if we look at you know what happened
after apartheid no that's such an
amazing idea that Desmond Tutu had to
say we need Truth and Reconciliation and
we needed that after this during some
rights you know we needed that after
slavery we needed that during other
social justice movements and I'm really
looking forward to that I you know I'm
happy to go to Davos or something and
start a always great to happen with
listen
back mirror will be available to stream
on Netflix starting December 29